[Musique]
face à l'urgence climatique
nous pensons que le co2 est l'ennemi
numéro un et si en fait il était la clé
pour le design propre de demain
transportons nous dans le futur
imaginons ensemble
l' usine du futur elle est comme la
société d'aujourd'hui
hyper connecté avec une interconnexion
des équipements de l'homme et du
territoire avec un nombre incalculable
de données traitées grâce au numérique
et à l'intelligence artificielle
explorons la plus avant elle est économe
en énergie et en matières premières
elle n'émet pas de rejet elle est
flexible et modulaire pour assurer une
souplesse de production on peut ainsi
produire adapter la production en
fonction des besoins et on peut même
proposer des produits personnalisés
customisés enfin les plus sûrs et limite
le risque d'accident en particulier
lorsque les installations sont de taille
réduite
en fin de compte dans l'industrie du
futur dès le début d'un projet
industriel son impact sur l'homme et sur
l'environnement est un critère
d'évaluation à part entière et c'est ça
qui est fondamental alors avec l'image
largement répandue d'une industrie qui
polluent on pourrait se dire qu'il va
falloir relever beaucoup de défis encore
pour que les usines répondent à ces
critères est bien la bonne nouvelle
c'est que cette révolution industrielle
la quatrième révolution industrielle est
d'ores et déjà en route
le concept d'industrie 4.0 a été évoqué
pour la toute première fois en 2011 en
allemagne lors d'un grand salon sur la
technologie industrielle et dès 2015 la
chine a lancé un plan décennal visant à
voir en 2025 donc une industrie
transformer donc ce concept d' usine 4.0
elle est maintenant au coeur de la
stratégie de beaucoup d'industries y
compris en france
elle est intégrée dans les programmes de
recherche et développement ce n'est plus
une tendance future c'est bien une
réalité
la preuve en images regardez cette usine
qui a été mise en service en 2018 en
australie c'est l'une des premières
usines entièrement digitalisé et
automatisée elle c'est une usine zéro
papier
la première dans ce secteur ce site
produit 75 millions de litres de
peinture par an avec des installations
de taille réduite et assure une
production customisés résultat la
consommation électrique a été réduite de
25% allons maintenant dans un secteur de
l'industrie réputé très polluant mais
qui a également amorcé sa transformation
c'est l'industrie du textile deux très
grandes marques de vêtements de sport
connu de tous utilisent désormais un
procédé sans eau pour colorer des
textiles
c'est un procédé zéro g comme sur cette
usine que vous voyez qui est à taïwan
alors vous vous questionnez sans doute
sur comment on peut colorer un textile
ou comment plus largement comment on
peut fabriquer tout un tas de produits
sans émettre de roger sans utiliser
d'eau sans utiliser de solvants
il existe plusieurs solutions
personnellement je peux en proposer une
et elle a un rapport avec ce fameux co2
alors vous connaissez ces grands
personnages que je n'ai pas besoin de
nommer
figurez vous que j'ai un point commun
avec eux nous sommes tous les trois
diplômé en génie des procédés
industriels
mais eux ont choisi une autre voie et
moi j'ai persévéré dans le domaine alors
le génie des procédés c'est quoi c'est
une science de l'ingénieur centré sur la
conception et l'optimisation de procédés
industriels
un chercheur en génie des procédés aide
à transformer les résultats de la
recherche parce qu'il y en a
souvent en réalisations industrielles
concrètes pour ma part après avoir fait
une thèse en génie des procédés j'ai
intégré un laboratoire de l'université
d'aix-marseille dont les recherches ont
pour objectif de développer des procédés
propres
alors au moment où j'ai démarré il ya
maintenant environ 25 ans les effluents
industriels étaient parfois rejetées
dans le milieu naturel sans aucun
traitement
on commençait à peine à parler de
valorisation de déchets bref il y avait
beaucoup à faire et c'est ça qui m'a
motivé le l'enjeu était était de taille
depuis les scientifiques ont développé
des procédés prom dans tout un tas de
secteurs de l'industrie
mais il faut encore poursuivre nos
efforts pour viser sans relâche cette
nouvelle industrie alors rentrons
maintenant dans le concret de celle ci
vous savez tous que sur la plupart des
sites industriels
on utilise des solvants organiques ils
sont indispensables pour extraire
nettoyer transformer un cerveau
organique c'est coin alors c'est là
s'étonne le méthanol des produits
chlorés que l'on retrouve couramment
dans l'industrie agroalimentaire des
parfums cosmétiques pharmaceutiques
mais le problème c'est que la grande
majorité des solvants sont des polluants
ils sont parfois inflammable souvent
toxiques pour l'homme et pour
l'environnement et l'impact de leur
utilisation sur l'environnement est
vraiment très important parce que il
faut les produire sur un site les
transporter sur les sites industriels où
ils vont être utilisés et il faudra
ensuite traiter les effluents pour
éliminer ou régénérer ses solvants
usagés et ça peut se faire seul on peut
faire ce traitement encore sur un
troisième site
donc l'enjeu est fort si l'on pouvait
réduire les quantités de solvants
utilisés dans l'industrie
cela contribuerait à voir des usines
propres et ce serait une avancée
significative pour la protection de
l'environnement
mais comment faire on peut tout à fait
utiliser un composé non toxique qui a
les mêmes propriétés que les
en organique et se compose et vous
l'aurez deviné c'est le co2 oui le co2
sous pression alors le co2 n'est pas
toxique on en consomme tous les jours
dans les boissons gazeuses et si on
l'utilisé dans certaines conditions de
pression et de température il a des
propriétés même plus avantageuses que
les solvants organiques liquide
alors là vous vous dites sûrement mais
le co2 c'est un gaz à effet de serre ça
ne peut pas être le solvant idéal c'est
vrai c'est un gaz à effet de serre et il
ya trop d'émissions de co2 il faut
absolument en maîtres - et dans la
mesure du possible essayez de valoriser
ce co2 qui est fatalement rejeté environ
5% des émissions de co2 sont liés aux
activités de production de l'industrie
chimique
on dit que c'est un sous produit lui
même produit en millions de tonnes
chaque année principalement lors de la
fabrication des ciments et dans une
moindre mesure lors de la synthèse des
engrais alors du co2 nous n'en manquons
pas et il peut conduire à une industrie
propre
voilà qui nous permet de penser économie
durable et circulaires parce que
finalement la meilleure solution c'est
de valoriser ce co2 et de l'utiliser
pour remplacer les solvants organiques
mais alors comment ça marche
vous vous rappelez sûrement des trois
états de la matière solide liquide gaz
ce qui est moins connu c'est que dans
certaines conditions de pression et de
température
la matière mais ni un solide ni un
liquide ni un gaz elle se présente sous
la forme d'un fluide qui a des
propriétés très particulière ce fluide
que l'on qualifie de supercritiques et
danse comme un liquide mais très peu
puisque comme un gaz il alors le pouvoir
solvants des liquides et les faits
pénétrant des gaz et ce sont ces
propriétés qui rendent possible la
production sans solvants organiques en
utilisant à la place un plus
père critique mais où en est-on de
l'utilisation du co2 sous pression alors
aujourd'hui il existe dans le monde
plusieurs centaines d'unités
industrielles qui utilisent le co2
supercritique comme celle que vous voyez
sur ces photos alors c'est dans
l'industrie agroalimentaire des parfums
des cosmétiques des médicaments à titre
d'exemple on peut faire du café
décaféiné avec du co2 on peut extraire
des principes actifs ou des composés
d'intérêt à partir de plantes de
produits naturels
la plupart des parfums contiennent un ou
plusieurs extraits co2 on peut colorer
des textiles comme on l'a vu tout à
l'heure on peut aussi mettre en forme
des médicaments et même stériliser en
utilisant du co2 supercritique
mais nous pourrions étendre davantage
son utilisation dans l'industrie
prenons l'exemple des huiles
alimentaires comme l'huile de colza et
l'huile de tournesol avant que l'huile
n'arrive dans nos assiettes
il y a plusieurs traitements il ya une
première étape qui consiste à récupérer
l'huile par un simple pressage mécanique
a froid on récupère alors de l'huile
propres en revanche la seconde étape est
une extraction par solvant en france on
utilise l'hexane il faut entre 500 kilos
et une tonne d'exane pour traiter une
tonne de graines mais après l'extraction
l'hexane puis plusieurs étapes de
séparation il reste malgré tout des
traces de solvant organique dans l'huile
alors quid de l'impact sur notre santé
quant au grain elles sont valorisées
dans l'alimentation animale en partie
pour les animaux d'élevage que l'on
retrouve ensuite dans nos assiettes
mais on peut tout à fait extraire de
huit cents seulement
en utilisant du co2 supercritique le co2
extrait de manière très sélective très
efficace l'huile et on récupère enfin de
procéder une huile propre par simple
dépression risation puisque le co2 se
séparent spontanément du produit fini
avant d'être recyclées
on peut donc avoir une huile et des
graines totalement exempte de traces de
solvants organiques produites sur des
sites on
utilise pas de solvants certains pays
asiatiques utilisent déjà cette
technologie à l'échelle industrielle
pour produire des huiles alimentaires
finalement lusine 4.0 cette usine
propres elles existent déjà mais elles
pourraient être plus présente en europe
alors il faut poursuivre nos efforts
pour faire en sorte que plus de sites
encore se transforme
il ya là un enjeu environnemental
important qui personnellement me
mobilise au quotidien et pour aller plus
loin il faut que les plus jeunes d'entre
vous s'oriente s'engage vers les métiers
de l'industrie 4.0 comme le génie des
procédés car vous et moi nous pourrions
ensemble bâtir un avenir meilleur
merci
[Musique]